studies suggest that many teenagers
they're just not getting enough sleep
the research adds fuel to the argument
that school start time should be moved
back the CDC estimates only 3 out of 10
high school students get their
recommended 8 to 10 hours a night only
15 percent of high school students
follow the American Academy of pediatric
advice and start at 8:30 or later so one
district that switched to a later start
time is giving the study's results very
high marks or dr. tehrani rule is here
with more on this story Tara good
morning to you good morning Gail after
the Seattle School District pushed
middle and high school opening from 750
to 8:45 a.m. science students had two of
those high schools became part of a
real-time experiment attempting to align
school schedules with the biological
clocks of adolescence mornings are a
little easier for hazel Ostrowski a
senior at Franklin High School in
Seattle she's able to sleep in a bit
longer thanks to a later start time of
8:45 set in place by her school district
two years ago I think I definitely felt
more awake when I had an extra hour
asleep hazel was one of more than a
hundred seventy students who took part
in a new study published Wednesday in
the journal Science advances it found
when school started later students slept
longer and their academic performance
improved I think that that really helped
me complete my schoolwork but also just
be more interested in what I was
learning researchers used wrist monitors
to measure how long two different groups
of sophomores slept one group was
monitored in 2016 when school started at
7:50 a.m. and the other group in 2017
when classes began almost an hour later
at 8:45 a.m. students who started class
later slept in extra 34 minutes on
school nights and their grades improved
an average of four and a half percent I
have seen that there are far fewer
tardies and absences in first period AJ
cats are off is Hazel's biology teacher
she worked with researchers on the study
and so improved student performance
firsthand I see kids are generally more
engaged in the work at the classroom so
very much more willing
to participate than in the past while
the study has shown positive results for
students health and academics it did not
address potentially negative impacts on
their after-school activities which now
might take place after dark when you
push the time back can be kind of
difficult especially if their outdoor
activities like sports
the researchers point out that most
teens simply cannot fall asleep before
11 p.m. or midnight so even though the
Seattle students are sleeping in average
34 minutes longer there's still only
getting an average of 7 hours and 24
minutes still short of the recommended 8
to 10 hours so why are the sleep needs
of teens different than other age groups
we spoke to the lead researcher and he
said there's really this misconception
that teens are just lazy and a lot of
parents think that their teens are
getting enough sleep but it's biology
and that when you hit puberty there is a
sleep wake delay that everything is
pushed back about two hours so in an
ideal scenario biologically teens would
want to go to sleep around 11 p.m. and
wake up around 8 and this is because the
circadian rhythm changes there's delayed
secretion of melatonin that kind of
pushes you to sleep later and you're not
as sensitive to the light in the morning
there's also a change in what we call
sleep pressure so every day when you
wake up the more hours you've been awake
that kind of accumulates and builds up a
drive for you to go to sleep at night in
teens they can kind of stay up longer
that plush pressure is changed and so
they don't really feel as tired as soon
as we would and so the researcher really
said look I mean this is like asking a
kid to get up at 4:30 in the morning
asking a kid to get up at 6:30 in the
morning and be alert know he's like
asking you or an adult to get up at 4:30
in the morning so certainly relate other
than the better grades what we do
everyone else except you all I was
saying yeah present company explain
other than better grades and attendance
are there other biological benefits to
this so really sleep impacts almost
every physiologic function and so
getting more sleep means less depression
and anxiety and teens less risk for
being overweight or obese and other
metabolic changes cardiovascular risk
factors also less risk for accidents
things like car accidents because of
fatigue or use of stimulants like
caffeine or other types of stimulant
drugs so really beneficial all the way
around and the American Academy of
Pediatrics made this
about crisis since 2014 we've known this
the CDC has weighed in so this is really
a nice big step in that direction and
something that we can do when it
modifies number one way to protect our
children really see there's a serious
issue for all ages you should do
something on morning shows Tara I would
love to start at 8:00 o'clock I know I
know it's a problem is anyone listening
no important it is really andrea's
adults need to take it seriously so we
lay that pattern virtual it set an
example that's right all right Thank You
Tara